he runs after me grabs me and he goes
what the are you doing and I go
live and bro and I punch him in the face
and run away like there's happy drunk
there's sad drunk I was run away driver
[Music]
yeah
very very funny man he's got his own
podcast called my junk friends get up
from the architecture man everybody
[Applause]
affected every area of my life it's
affected my relationship with women and
my relationship with sex this is small
aside I spent $1,500 to have a escort
come over one night and I couldn't get
it up so I just spent all night holding
her hand like it was the first day like
hey my pastor can we do that animal
cracker scene from Armageddon it's
affected my relationship with my family
my family was once I was naked in my
parents living room doing line snake
it's the official uniform of cocaine by
the way that's like Superman's cape and
they came home early and the only thing
that I could think to say was huh-huh
don't come in I'm masturbating you know
your wife's in a sad place if
masturbation is the safe option with
your parents and then when they turn
their back I took the rest of the
cocaine put it in a bag and shoved it up
my ass so I could do the cocaine in the
basement while they were asleep before
they got up for work at 6:00 a.m. I did
coke the same way Gollum eats it's it's
affected our my relationships with my
friends my friendships when I was 20
years old I was actually a janitor at a
middle school which at the time didn't
fit now now it looks like it fits like
now
now I look like the guys like hey if you
kids want to miss dodgeball I'll tell
you how I got this hook you know but uh
the time it didn't fit I was very clean
face and my friend called me up and he
said hey I got tickets to the gathering
of the vibes this Jam bein Festival in
upstate New York yeah it's all it was
like I had like I had a really I went
there in high school I had a really fun
time there in high school did a lot of
drugs
I met a chick it was great right
and I'm 20 I right at this point like
I'm getting way more fights it's like my
up times been way more dark but
I'm excited because I'm like working the
shitty job my wife's in a shitty place
I'm like all right I have something to
look forward to on one of these janitor
weekends sounds like the worst buddy
comedy ever get ready for janitor
weekend starring Zach Braff and another
Zach movie anyway my friend picks me up
we stopped at my friend John he picks me
up we stopped at the liquor store he
already should have known there was
gonna be a problem that weekend because
he got a 12-pack of beer and I bought
like a handle of black velvet whiskey is
it oh my god there's like that's like
that's like what you drink and I you
know like a baby shower on Deadwood you
know so we get we get the car I'm
getting like hammered the whole
trip to this and I mean I'm just kidding
I'm just getting drunkards I'm not
making I'm like starting to argue with
him like it's not making any sense and
we get to the gathering of the vibes and
this like gathering the vibes has
changed since the like last time I was
there it was like peace love and
understanding now there's like one good
vibe and all the other vibes are I
wonder how much ecstasy I can get if I
steal that guy's iPod you know and we
like we're in the car we're arguing and
then all of a sudden like we're online
we're in a car line waiting to go into
this festival and the back door opens
and I swear got this old man walks in
and he looked like imagine if like
Burt's Bees had like a cousin but
instead of selling be he
sold the milk he squeezed from possums
you know he sits down and we look at him
and he just goes don't mind me passing
through and he passes out in the back
like it like it was a bonus round on
Oregon Trail but I'm such a drop my
friend doesn't even notice that because
I'm a wreck like I'm already
yelling at him and I'm like I'm like
he's like stop with the air
conditioner and I'm like your mom's and
hair conditioner he's think that doesn't
make any sense
stop playing Stevie Nicks landslide I'm
like it's a good song go yourself
we're fighting back and forth we're
fighting so much that in the middle of
it the old guy just wakes up and he goes
okay and he leaves like I was so
annoying I made a hobo turn down shelter
that's how annoying I was he's like I
rather die in the cold than deal with
this I'm going back to hobo Island
but we're fighting more and more I you
know we're coming down to the ten area
he's like you you he's like
what's your problem
the Iraq war was wrong he's like you're
not making any sense I jump out of the
car as it's driving now this sounds of
like very Lethal Weapon II and
impressive but the car was only going
ten miles an hour so it just looked like
the most low stakes hostage situation
ever
so he stops the car he runs after me
grabs me and he goes what the are
you doing and I go live and bro and I
punch him in the face and run away like
there's happy drunk
there's sad drunk I was run away drunk I
don't remember much of the night what I
do remember is I remember I take it to
hits acid and I was nervous because I
drank so much that I was gonna pass out
and not experience the acid so I bought
a gram of cocaine that I immediately did
to my dome and I remember I turned to
the guy who sold me the cocaine and I'm
like oh you want to talk now and he goes
I'm cool and he walks away he's probably
a doctor now and then that's all I
remember I pass out and then I woke up
the next day and I was in my friends
trunk and the trunk was open and my
friend is like sitting in the corner
like he's like a sailor one of those
like camp chairs and he's smoking a
cigarette and he's looking off into the
distance and it's this that palpable
feeling of I up you know and I
turned to him and I'm like hey John he
goes what I'm sorry he goes sorry for
what for punching you in the face and
then he goes the first time or the
second time apparently later the night I
punched I walked away I found like like
this like little creek near the tonight
Creek it was like just kind of a ditch
and I started like puking because I was
hungover from that it looked
like the whole thing we picked the most
white trash Ansel Adams photo ever and
then this dude comes up and back at me
and then I just hear Rico and I'm like
forcing myself to puke and he's like
Rico I'm not Rico I'm not Rico and he
goes no you're Rico I'm like nah
tree and then he takes out his digital
camera and he shows the pictures and I
had been partying with that guy the
night before and told him my name was
Riga
and I got my I'm so sorry he goes now
don't worry man you were
hilarious she told great stories you
helped my friend Mike for a breakup you
like played him this Bob Dylan song it
helps he goes has Law School go and I
told him I was going to law school
it's good it's good and then he goes
dude come here come here and then he
like puts a clump of mushrooms
in my hand and I look at it and I'm like
well when in upstate New York and I eat
the mushrooms cut to like a half hour
later at this point I'm like starting to
feel the body buzz and he goes hey dance
for us like you did last night so I
start dancing and they think it's
hilarious but I think it's sexy cuz I'm
trippin like it looked like if Jabba
dance for Leia you know it was like the
opposite of what it normally is so and
then I start dancing away from them but
then they follow me and we're all
dancing in this line through the
festival and in the distance I see my
friend John and he looks at me she goes
what the damn it's not dan its
Regan
and then he goes it's damn it
was like no it's Rico and then Jonathan
gets dead and then the guy reaches in
his pocket pulls out some more mushrooms
goes up to my friend John puts it in his
hand and if friend John looks at the
mushroom he goes you know you know Dan
was rude obnoxious violent drunk last
night but this guy Rico well he seems
pretty cool any of the mushrooms that we
all party together
it was two rehabs later I'm still
dancing guys thank you so much have a
good
[Music]